there was three unidentified flying
objects flying over America and got shot
down they haven't retrieved no wreckage
they told us they don't know it they
don't think it's from China they don't
know where it's from and nobody gave a
[__] you know what I mean like the
possibility of nuclear war I'm not
saying it's high but it's higher than
it's probably ever been in our lifetime
and nobody gives a [__] yeah no you know
what I mean like nobody like nobody
gives a [__] there's too much cheap
distraction it's like you anybody it as
long as you have enough money to have a
phone and an internet connection you can
go on Tick Tock or Instagram or YouTube
and be distracted for eight hours a day
and have the time of your [__] life
that's never existed before yeah people
are bored before so when you're bored
and poor you get to focus on how broke
you are yeah that [__] sucks I also I
think the size of the threat makes a
difference like if you learn like a
bigger than nuclear war no but that's my
point though is like if you learn that
like oh there's a serial kill in my area
and he might come in my house I feel
like people get scared because they can
control it I can fight one guy but when
it's like hey the whole planet might get
eviscerated people go all right I think
there's a piece in how destructive it's
interesting I think the news has been
pump faking so long that we don't care
absolutely everything and we have this
perfect distraction I'm telling you if
you took away everybody's phones
and we were getting news that Biden gave
a billion dollars to Ukraine Jesus we
would show up at the [__] white house
it's been 30 billion dollars
if we found that but the fact that we
all have our phones and we can just
laugh at a video laugh at another video
laugh in another video and just go on
our lives play a [__] video game just
distraction distraction distraction the
new opiate of the masses dude yeah but
it's like it's like what is it give them
uh give them a circus give them bread
and circus right the problem is the
Romans didn't have enough circus you
have one of these fights every month or
something like that every second you got
a new yeah Coliseum they didn't have
enough circuits you think the Romans
knew that their empire was falling
when it was actually falling do you
think they knew I think probably was too
late by the time they realized that's
what America that's what we're at right
now
it's a different time it's a different
time
because we got the nukes bro it's a
different time so rushing out more
I don't have any confidence they could
actually get them here yeah
Marine is 10 to 15. so they say
I'm not even they can even invade
Ukraine yeah I mean like I need to see
you snatch up Ukraine it might not be
the best on land
um but when it comes to hitting that
button that's what they would like you
to believe I'm not as worried about
nukes because there's so many we can
destroy each other's entire countries
the entire world so it's like but we're
always going for those nukes but I think
financially and all that stuff I'm
worried more about other countries
coming up like China or whoever oh China
China China Ben did that play China
China been buying up everything in uh
Africa and the Caribbean parts of
America like China's been playing the
long game we lost I think we've lost the
financial game to China already and
that's really to me the game now yeah
yeah yeah I can see that it's all about
the money trying to think did you see
did you see the article that said Donald
Trump was was going to hit the nuke on
North Korea
no that would have been sick
no North Koreans coming to car shows
anymore
the rebound from new
Port News if you think about it like
what Japan is way better off
do you know what I mean like if we're
Japan before they
they would Samurai and the shingled roof
to like technological superpowers you
know how burning down a forest makes the
soil more fertile yeah
[Laughter]
that did happen so it's not like this it
might help North Korea they might need a
reset they might need to take the game I
don't think there would be any more
North Korea if a new guy dropped on
their careers
a little and how do you and how do you
do that without how do you know Korea
how do you do that without blowing up
South Korea how do you do that without
blowing up South Korea too I mean
they're right by each other for every
Dice Game Jesus Christ now I don't want
this to happen I don't want this to
happen but so far
we've had a good a good record when it
comes to like you know I'm moving over
to akash's point like nobody wants to go
nuke for nuke everybody knows you go
nuke for nuke it's over yeah but how
desperate is Russia right now we don't
know you know what I'm saying like
they're saying that this war is like
putting a screen on Russia that they've
never felt before and they're talking
about the health of Putin he might just
be like [__] it yeah you know what I
mean I ain't gonna be here one last ride
why not yeah bro bro if they blow us up
we blow them up it's over everything's
done if I'm the leader that's going
anyway
we'll take them out nobody will remember
his name because we're all dead Lindsey
Grant Lindsey Graham told y'all what to
do but y'all act like old ladybug was
bugging ladybug says somebody need to
take about
I think we probably tried you think so
yeah I mean he can't even [__] alone
have you seen him go to the bathroom
with other people
like a girl he shits like a like a I
don't think they have drones inside the
Ant-Man yet say again you don't think
they have drones I think we do yeah you
saw that tiny camera there's a new
camera that came out it's like the size
of like a grain of rice or smaller and
it takes like a 480p picture it's insane
but it's like you can stick it on a wall
that's [__] up yeah so then yeah so we
should probably run that up he'd be
knowing some weird [__] yeah it's gonna
be useful